pour cause de grève demain plusieurs
associations dont le mrap ont décidé de
commémorer avec un jour d'avancé
l'un des évènements les moins connus de
la guerre d'algérie les faits remontent
au 17 octobre 1961 au quartier latin
une manifestation de musulmans d'algérie
a été réprimée avec une incroyable
violence par les forces de l'ordre
bilan officiel selon le préfet de police
de l'époque maurice papon trois morts le
bilan a été en réalité beaucoup plus
lourd en réalité il y en a eu au minimum
200 et je pense que la réalité tourner
probablement autour de 300 des morts
sous quelle forme
les un grand nombre de morts par noyade
des morts tués par balles des morts
tente des lieux d'internement notamment
au palais des sports de la porte de
versailles dans la cour de la préfecture
de police dans l'enceinte même de la
préfecture de police au stade de
coubertin
on a tué des hommes dans des lieux
d'internement
ce jour là les associations qui célèbre
ce soir ce sinistre anniversaire
souhaite ainsi lutter contre le racisme
en rappelant l'existence du drame un
drame qui ne figure c'est ce qu'elle
souligne dans aucun manuel scolaire
traitant de la guerre d'algérie
mesdames et messieurs bonjour le procès
maurice papon l'audience d'hier fut en
tout point très particulière car on peut
dire que l'ancien ministre est
véritablement entré dans son procès j'ai
sauvé des juifs pendant l'occupation at
il affirmé
il s'est longuement exprimé sur sa
carrière l'ancien préfet de police de
paris a ainsi donné sa version sur la
répression policière contre la
manifestation du 17 octobre 61 cours de
laquelle 200 algériens auraient été tués
emmanuel gagné joseph tual christian de
carnets octobre 61 maurice papon préfet
de police de paris impose le couvre-feu
à la population algérienne pour
protester contre cette mesure
d'exception
le fln appelle à manifester le 17
octobre
trente mille algériens et leurs familles
se rassemblent à paris en face dix mille
hommes chargé de disperser la
manifestation interdite
la répression policière sera impitoyable
bilan officiel de morts et 64 blessés
pour le fln il y a plus de 200 tués hier
à l'audience
maurice papon a parlé d'une vingtaine de
victimes des dissidents qui aurait été
assassinée par des commandos du fln
c'est une contre vérité historique
flagrante faut aussi quand même tenir
compte de la parole des témoins et des
acteurs ce que maurice papon évidemment
oublier absolument de mentionner dans
ses interventions c'est à dire qu'il
espèce de négation du fait historique
sur le 17 octobre 61 avocats du fln
pendant la guerre d'algérie m oussedik
va plus loin
maurice papon en 61 ce serait une
répétition de l'histoire en lui un parti
une mission bien précise se cacher le
fln dans la région parisienne et il a
mis en place des méthodes qu'il avait
certainement dû utiliser du vent
l'occupation semer la terreur au sein de
l'immigration afin de lâcher paris qui
organise âge
que s'est il exactement passé le 17
octobre 1961
quelle est la responsabilité de maurice
papon dans la répression policière pour
répondre à ces questions
il faudra attendre 2021 à cette date les
archives révéleront peut-être lors
douloureux et tragique secret et ce
procès décidément l'occasion de revenir
sur des événements historiques
trente six ans après les faits la
manifestation du 17 octobre 61 été
beaucoup évoqué une manifestation
violemment réprimée qui avait causé la
mort de 200 algériens à l'époque maurice
papon était préfet de police à paris et
le climat était particulièrement tendue
dans la capitale
emmanuel gagné joseph tual octobre 61
maurice papon préfet de police de paris
impose le couvre-feu pour protester
contre cette mesure d'exception
le fln appelle à manifester
pacifiquement le 17 octobre
trente mille algériens et leurs familles
se rassemblent dans les rues de paris
face à eux dix mille hommes chargé de
disperser cette manifestation interdite
la répression policière sera sanglante
bilan officiel de morts 64 blessés et
des milliers d'interpellations hier à
l'audience
maurice papon admettez que des victimes
sur dix fois plus nombreuses aujourd'hui
à la demande des parties civiles
jean luc einaudi historien est venu
témoigner à la barre pour lui maurice
papon serait bien le responsable des
violences policières
maurice papon pour prendre un seul
exemple il y a eu ce jour-là un certain
nombre de forces nouvelles qui ont
circulé sur les ondes de la police
faisant état de policiers qui venaient
de curé
art
des algériens ce qui est absolument faux
seins et bien le préfet police n'a pris
aucune initiative pour démentir ces
fausses nouvelles et ont contribué à
exacerber la haine maurice papon affirme
qu'il n'a fait qu'obéir et d'après lui
les victimes du 17 octobre seraient des
dissidents assassiné par les commandos
du fln mais pour cet avocat du mouvement
nationaliste pendant la guerre d'algérie
maurice papon en 61 ce ne serait qu'une
répétition de l'histoire on est un parti
une mission bien précise se cacher le
fln dans la région parisienne et il a
mis en place des méthodes qu'il avait
certainement dû utiliser du vent
l'occupation que s'est il exactement
passé le 17 octobre 61
quelle est la responsabilité de maurice
papon dans la répression policière
pour tenter de répondre à ces questions
catherine trautmann ministre de la
culture vient d'annoncer qu'elle demande
dès l'ouverture des archives le procès
papon avec un témoin prestigieux
aujourd'hui à la barre puisqu'il
s'agissait de l'ancien premier ministre
pierre messmer cité par la défense
c'est-à-dire par l'avocat de maurice
papon
il a pourtant refusé de le soutenir il
affirme aussi qu'il ne veut pas que la
france soit rendu responsable des crimes
de vichy albert ripamonti pierre dick
gaullistes historiques témoigne ministre
des armées du général premier ministre
de georges pompidou
pierre messmer a côtoyé maurice papon à
partir de 1958 quand celui ci était
préfet de police de paris
homme de devoir pierre messmer est
convoqué il vient feu survenu ni accusé
ni défendre je suis cité à témoigner
sous le serment et je n'ai pas
l'habitude quand je suis cité de me
retrouver à la barre ce héros de la
france libre ne se dérobe pas sans
indulgence pour vichy ce pouvoir
illégitime sévère avec la préfectorale
d'alors beaucoup de ses membres dit il
aurait dû démissionner dans le box
maurice papon à l'air nerveux
et m e varaut intervient un jury
d'honneur a reconnu sa qualité de
résistants le témoin hésite il est très
difficile de répondre
m e varaut insiste en pure perte le
compagnon du général de gaulle n'est pas
venu pour soutenir l'ancien préfet seul
réconfort à propos de la répression
d'octobre 61
pierre messmer au nom du gouvernement de
l'époque a su vous est alors qu'on ne
s'y attendait pas pierre messmer va
laisser éclater son courroux contre ce
qu'ils appellent les plus hautes
autorités de l'état
imputée à la france et aux français la
responsabilité des crimes de vichy est
intolérable et il se répète
le gaulliste de la première heure viser
d'abord jacques chirac et sa déclaration
au vel d'hiv en juillet 95 et là nous
n'étions plus dans le procès papon
mais dans celui de notre histoire
on peut sans
mais à l'occasion du procès de maurice
papon ne parle donc pas seulement de son
action pendant l'occupation les témoins
évoquent vous l'avez entendu également
son attitude pendant la guerre d'algérie
et notamment lorsque préfet de paris le
17 octobre 1961 il était en titre le
responsable de la police à l'occasion de
la tragique manifestation organisée par
le fln qui se termina dans un bain de
sang philippe boisserie eric lemasson
jamais mohamed ou sic n'oubliera ce 17
octobre 1961
ils voulaient manifester contre le
couvre-feu imposé aux algériens et pour
l'algérie indépendante responsable du
fln il avait mobilisé ses troupes dans
le bidonville de nanterre
mais l'histoire s'est arrêtée
brutalement ici sur le pont de neuilly à
ce moment là l'étau s'est resserré sur
les algériens
la police est à ce moment-là et rené des
algériens et les gp à la scène et puis
voilà ils ont chargé c'est la peur ils
ont tiré
les housses ou tel camp quoi et un petit
muret l'inca et s'ils se sauver il a été
pris par une rafale est mort et je suis
assez blessé
à l'époque seules ces images muettes
furent diffusés celle d' arrestations de
masse parmi les trente mille algériens
descendus dans les rues de paris
les photos délicat quand elle posé
problème à deux journaux qu'ils ont fusé
la vie catholique lundi s on forme il ya
des photos mais elles vont choquer mais
lecteurs il m'a fait un bond de profs en
francs mais vit les impôts publié à
france nouvelle ils m'ont dit thierry
thierry técher tous n'ont pas les saisir
on peut on va essayer ici si on les fait
mumuse michel rollin la journal les
autobus de la ratp réquisitionné avec
leur chauffeur emmène des milliers d'
interpeller porte de versailles
joseph comme un chant gère lui-même
gardiens de la paix préférerait ne pas
s'en souvenir
au fur et à mesure que c'est qu'à
l'arrivée j'étais des charges et manu
militari projetait pas refaire est
frappé par une double haie de
deux gardiens de la paix qui se disait
comité d'accueil et avait la radio qui
marchait et on disait dans l
arrondissement et a eu deux tués deux
gardiens de la paix tués dans l autre 5
tel autre 6 et c'est donc c'était une
intoxication pur tôt sachant pour
exciter les troupes
plus tard dans la nuit il s'est produit
encore des événements beaucoup plus
tragique un puisqu'une cinquantaine
d'algériens ont été tués alors que
maurice papon était présent à la
préfecture tué puis ensuite leurs corps
ont été jetés à la seine
à l'époque des élus de paris des
sénateurs demandent r&d commission
denquête elles furent toutes refusé
pendant de très longues années un
silence de plomb pesant sur ces
événements trente ans plus tard en 1991
le quid ne parle que de deux morts et 44
blessés
en 1998 on en est à six morts précision
entre parenthèses 200 morts selon le fln
sans doute un minimum la guerre
d'algérie reste une page grise de notre
histoire tout à l'heure en effet dans
les débats on reviendra sur le rôle de
maurice papon durant les événements
d'algérie il était préfet police à paris
lorsqu'une répression sanglante a eu
lieu
c'était le 17 octobre 1961 rappel des
faits gilles marine et 17 octobre 1961
20h30 venue des bidonvilles de nanterre
et du xviiie arrondissement de paris
trente mille manifestants se dirigent
vers les champs elysées des algériens
qui réclame la levée du couvre-feu
instauré quelques jours plus tôt par le
préfet de police maurice papon
le rassemblement est interdite en vertu
du couvre-feu tout ressortissant
algérien manifestants ou non peut être
mis en état d'arrestation
dix mille policiers crs gendarmes
mobiles vont s'en charger de la manière
la plus brutale
lorsqu'un message radio de la police
indique à tort le décès de plusieurs
gendarmes la répression tourne à
l'hystérie meurtrière des manifestants
sont tués par balles d'autres jetés dans
la seine les hauts d'abord et après nous
mais hier les accusations se sont
également portées contre l'ancien préfet
de police de paris là encore maurice
papon minimise son rôle se retranche
derrière les hiérarchies événements
d'algérie vichy maurice papon donne sa
version des faits mais à partir de cet
après midi des témoins ont raconté
l'histoire
l'ouverture des archives annoncé hier
par catherine trautmann ministre de la
culture devrait permettre de faire la
vérité sur cette nuit du 17 octobre 61
ou une manifestation d'algériens
durement réprimée a fait de nombreuses
victimes jamais comptabilisés dans les
bilans officiels
cette décision de lever le secret sur
des documents qui dorment depuis 36 ans
suscite des réactions mitigées des
syndicats de police reste que cette
décision donnera en même temps un nouvel
éclairage sur la responsabilité de
maurice papon alors préfet de police
philippe boisserie valérie fournier
ouvrir les archives il est aussi facile
de le dire que mal aisé de le faire les
portes de notre mémoire ont la
réputation d'être lourde surtout
lorsqu'il s'agit d'une page sombre de
notre histoire
les questions sur ce 17 octobre 1961
sont durs y at il eu lors de cette
manifestation du fln contre le
couvre-feu imposé aux algériens et pour
l'algérie indépendante
trois morts selon le bilan officiel ou
200 ans et plus selon les travaux
récents d'historiens
y at il eu volonté politique ou non de
réprimer qui est responsable
la police le préfet le gouvernement les
premières réactions sur cette ouverture
des archives celle des syndicats de
policiers sont partagés
voir opposer si la police nationale qui
peine tout au moins c'est ce qu'ils
ressentent et qui est mise en cause et
je crois pas qu'aujourd'hui fait thomas
ma connaissance on puisse accuser la
police nationale de quoi que ce soit
c'est une institution qui fonctionne
tout à fait démocratique manque
inarrêtable à une institution
républicaine et le vivre dans ma le
temps final je crois que quand on
pratique le culte du secret quand on ne
dit pas les choses c'est que ça cache
quelque chose
or je pense que nous avons seulement
rien à cacher n'avons pas à rougir de la
police nationale n'avons pas à rougir
notre nation nous n'avons pas à rougir
de la république française un débat
exacerbée par le procès de maurice papon
le préfet de police de l'époque
hier pierre messmer ministre des armées
en 1961 le dédouaner de toute
responsabilité
aujourd'hui celui-ci applaudi à
l'ouverture des archives rappelle le
climat de l'époque celui de la guerre
d'algérie et apporte un bémol sur les
responsabilités à la responsabilité de
la décision de réagir fermement contre
la manifestation
c'est la responsabilité du gouvernement
et aucun doute s'il ya eu des bavures
c'est aussi leur responsabilité du
gouvernement
s'il ya eu des crimes ou pas ont duré du
crime c'est tout autre chose mais pour
savoir il faut trouver les archives
notamment celle de la préfecture de
police
or celles ci sont légalement protégé
jusqu'en 2021
il faudra donc des circulaires peut être
des lois et puis il faudra regrouper les
documents disséminés dans les différents
services de police que donneront ces
services aux archives
la vérité est sans doute au bout d'un
chemin encore très tortueux l'examen du
profil psychologique de maurice papon se
poursuit devant la cour d'assises de
gironde et paradoxalement c'est plus sur
la période de la guerre d'algérie que se
portent les projecteurs jusqu'à présent
l'ouverture des archives décidé par
catherine trautmann permet d'apporter
des éléments de confirmation à la thèse
de la sanglante répression policière de
la manifestation des algériens du 17
octobre 1961
dominique verdeilhan h hne lamerat morts
béroud s abdelkader mort mais le couvent
amar mort tous sont des français
musulmans d'algérie mort à paris en 61
motif de leur décès homicide volontaire
autrement dit meurtre
autre colonne le nom du magistrat
instructeur et surtout la décision
judiciaire qui a suivi une enquête
enel non lieu ainsi la justice a refermé
le dossier
ce document du parquet de paris sorti
des archives fait état d'au moins 70
morts après la manifestation d'octobre
61 70 cents 300 morts hier à l'audience
maurice papon a contesté ces chiffres il
se retranche derrière le bilan officiel
trois morts à la rigueur il concède 30
décès mais c'est un règlement de comptes
interne au fln dit il pèse soutenu hier
à la barre par un ancien collaborateur
de maurice papon soirée centre de paris
sur le parvis notre dame
on puisera sa cible et 40 50 personnes
enfin pu refaire fun le poum d'un ton
gaullien maurice papon devait rajouter
s'il ne s'agissait que de moi ça serait
peu de choses mais la france tant que
j'aurai un souffle je ne laisserai pas
touché seulement aujourd'hui des
documents contredisent les dires de
maurice papon les archives d'un massacre
le 17 octobre 1961
plusieurs dizaines de manifestants ont
trouvé la mort c'est la conclusion d'un
premier rapport révélé par le figaro
pour les associations il manque encore
plusieurs pièces dans ce dossier
reportages emmanuel les gagner et jean
bernard et hier ces sommes parqués les
bras levés derrière des barrières
métalliques
ce sont quelques-uns des 25 mille
algériens français qui se sont
rassemblés rue de paris en cette soirée
du 17 octobre 61
quelques instants plus tôt à l'appel du
fln ils manifestaient pacifiquement pour
protester contre le couvre feu qui leur
est imposé ces images ne montrent pas
mais la répression policière est très
dur voilà ce que confirme un rapport
commandé il ya six mois par le
gouvernement
d'après un bilan officiel de l'époque
cette répression aurait fait sept morts
des centaines affirmé le fln aujourd'hui
les auteurs du rapport estiment que le
nombre des victimes se chiffrent en
dizaines minorant les estimations de
certains chercheurs ce qui s'est passé
ici après ses factures des gens ont été
balancés dans la seine
il faut que toute la vérité soit faite
aujourd'hui c'est un début de
reconnaissance
ce n'est qu'un début de vérité j'espère
que demain on y arrivera à la vérité
totale sur cet événement leur apportons
aussi de comprendre les causes de ce
déchaînement de violence dispositif
policier des
dans l'urgence peur des débordements et
surtout des forces de l'ordre qui ont
perdu 22 des leurs lors d'attentats
perpétrés par les nationalistes
algériens dans les mois précédents une
analyse que ne partage pas l'un des
meilleurs connaisseurs du dossier
il ne faut pas qu'en 1998 une nouvelle
vérité qui serait une vérité officielle
viennent prendre la place d'une autre
vérité celle de 1961 qui s'est avérée
mensongère les auteurs du rapport le
reconnaissent eux mêmes c'est maintenant
aux historiens de prendre le relais mais
le travail sera difficile certaines
archives comme celle de la brigade
fluviale ont été détruites
si maurice papon se porte partie civile
c'est pour cet article paru dans le
monde du 20 mai dernier
l'historien jean luc einaudi met en
cause sa responsabilité directe dans la
répression sanglante de la manifestation
d'algériens du 17 octobre 1961 préfet de
police à l'époque des faits maurice
papon attaque l'historien pour
complicité de diffamation envers un
fonctionnaire public
il réclame un million de francs de
dommages intérêts
cette plainte n'était en aucune manière
une manoeuvre
c'est simplement le droit légitime car
maurice papon de faire cesser la pseudo
historien et de faire taire un pseudo
historien qu'il le dit femme depuis 15
ans
jean luc et nous dit et pourtant
l'auteur d'un ouvrage de référence sur
les événements d'octobre 1961 il a
également témoigné sur cette affaire
dans le cadre du procès papon devant la
justice il contenir défendre son travail
d'historien puisque maurice papon me
poursuivre en justice
eh bien je vais répondre évidemment je
vais faire citer des témoins et il sera
établi qu'il ya eu un massacre commis
sous la responsabilité de maurice papon
en attendant jean-luc einaudi a reçu le
soutien du mrap
une pétition en sa faveur a déjà
recueilli la signature de 200
personnalités
le procès lui est fixée au 4 février
un procès qui aura au moins le mérite de
relancer le débat sur les
responsabilités exactes du massacre du
17 octobre 1961
maurice papon va se retrouver jeudi le
nouveau devant un tribunal mais cette
fois ci c'est lui qui porte plainte il
poursuit en diffamation l'historien jean
luc einaudi pour ses propos dans le
monde sans la répression de la
manifestation algérienne du 17 octobre
61 en quête de nos confrères de france 3
2 france 3 et manuel gagner bruno
l'hiver tout ce soir là lorsqu'il sort
du métro wazemmes saada les mains sur la
tête pour se protéger des coups de
matraque
comme des milliers d'autres algériens se
rendre du fln le mouvement
indépendantiste
il est venu manifester pacifiquement à
paris contre le couvre feu les forces de
l'ordre les attendent à faire sur nous
un carnage par tous les moyens ce qu'ils
avaient dans le soulèvement
on peut pas voter à cesser des barres de
fer ou les matraques ou des coups de
crosse bilan officiel de la répression
policière trois morts 200 d'après le fln
une centaine selon cet ancien
responsable syndical de la police
étaient des garçons s'inviter à notre
c'est notre organisation
or tous deux ont dit que j'étais là ils
ont reçu plus d'une centaine de cadavres
et que pour évacuer on rejetait souvent
les canards à la scène les raisons de ce
déchaînement des forces de l'ordre les
attentats du fln contre les policiers
dans les mois précédents mais aussi ce
17 octobre
d'étranges rumeurs sur les ondes de la
police il a été dit que des collègues
auraient été tirés auraient été abattus
par part des nord africains s'étaient
entièrement fond mais pour certains le
responsable de ce drame se serait
maurice papon alors préfet de police de
paris
papon a eu cette parole dramatique pour
un coup reçu
nous entendrons 10 mais dans le climat
qui avait à ce moment-là et formation ça
a été interprété inévitablement pour un
tué en nature à 10 cet ancien
collaborateur de maurice papon est
formel le fln porterait la
responsabilité des violences
on pouvait pas tolérer qu'ils aillent
manifester sous les fenêtres du général
de gaulle nous l'accorderez quand même
c'était pas pensable
c'était pas pense à pommes et etc aurait
pensé l'armée française en algérie
alors quand alors qu'on essaie tout
faire ici ce n'est pas possible
un débat sur lequel la justice va se
pencher à partir de demain les juges
devront dire si l'historien jean luc
einaudi à diffamer maurice papon en
affirmant publiquement que l'ancien
préfet était responsable de la mort de
plusieurs centaines d'algériens
c'est pts de regarder les pages sombres
de son histoire après vichy c'est au
tour de la guerre d'algérie demain ou
commémore un épisode tragique de ce
conflit le 17 octobre 61 à paris la
police suez des manifestants proches du
fln à l'époque un bilan faisait état de
trois morts
depuis on sait que les victimes ont été
très nombreuses l'ouverture des archives
aux historiens le confirme emmanuel
gagner de nos villes de cette soirée ne
reste que ces images d'hommes mains sur
la tête
la peur dans les yeux à l'appel du fln
ils étaient venus manifester à paris
pour dénoncer le couvre-feu un
couvre-feu qui venait d'être imposés à
la population algérienne
ce 17 octobre 61 les forces de l'ordre
vont faire payer très cher à ces
manifestants pacifiques
la mort de leur collègue policier
assassiné par le fln dans les mois
précédents là devant la préfecture de
police devant le palais de justice
des algériens ont été jetés à la seine
du haut de ce pont 1
il est bien évident que les policiers
qui ont commis ces crimes
ici en plein coeur de paris l'ont fait
avec le sentiment de l'impunité depuis
des années jean luc einaudi accumule
inlassablement des témoignages sur les
violences policières du 17 octobre et
des jours qui ont suivi depuis longtemps
aussi
il a réclamé la possibilité de consulter
les archives de la préfecture de police
de paris
son obstination a fini par payer et les
portes se sont ouvertes des documents
conservés ici dans cette salle et que
nous avons été autorisés
exceptionnellement à filmer des dizaines
de cartons rouges qui renferme notamment
ce type d'information c'est un
commissaire de police du vième
arrondissement qui fait un compte rendu
à son chef extraits de ce document la
police secours est intervenu et pour les
disperser comme il se montrait menaçant
a fait usage des armes
il ya aussi cette note de maurice papon
alors préfet de police premier bilan
officiel de la manifestation de
et puis ce gros cahier le registre de
l'institut médico-légal la morgue
près de 300 corps d'algériens pour
l'année 61
au fil des pages des noms parfois une
photo les causes présumées de la mort
mais rien bien sûr sur les circonstances
il faut aller dans les dossiers de la
police judiciaire à son nom pour trouver
l'enquète qui a été fait par la police
étudier les dossiers judiciaires
c'est le travail mené par sat historiens
un travail pour tenter d'établir
notamment le nombre d'algériens tué par
les policiers le 17 octobre et les jours
suivants voici son estimation
j'arrive si vous voulez à une trentaine
de morts
pour faire fut sceptiques d'être
attribué à la police mais dans certains
cas on ne saura jamais si c'est
exactement à la police et donc je dis je
voulais ça peut monter peut-être jusqu'à
une cinquantaine mais ça ne m'étonnerait
beaucoup qu'on aille beaucoup plus loin
pour jean luc einaudi ce bilan est
beaucoup plus élevée 200 morts
il ya des témoignages également qui font
état de deux morts à la préfecture de
police au palais des sports au parc des
expositions je dois dire que jusqu'à ce
jour on n'a pas retrouvé trace de ces
cadavres
on ignore toujours ce qu'il est advenu
de ces cadavres dans ce débat un peu
macabre
une seule certitude le 17 octobre 61
restera l'une des pages les plus sombres
de l'histoire de la vème république
rappelons le très tendues avaient appelé
à cette manifestation